[Music]
we are getting our first look at a
virgin galactic spaceship that could
soon take private passengers
into space spaceship 3 will fly
researchers and tourists about 50 miles
above earth's surface
that is about seven times higher than a
commercial airplane's cruising altitude
and passengers will experience several
minutes of
weightlessness on the journey the
company expects the first launch to be
early next year
that's the current estimate tickets have
sold for 250
000 but that price is likely to go
up first on cbs this morning virgin
group founder sir richard branson joins
us
with virgin galactic ceo michael cole
glazer good morning to both of you
i am personally as a member of the
public very excited at the prospect of
traveling into space so my first
question to you
uh sir richard branson this has been
about a 10-year effort uh maybe even a
little bit more
this is spaceship three how is this
design
different and what makes you excited
about it in particular
well just looking at those pictures
again um
i remember as a kid um thinking
you know what i'd love what i thought
what i've envisaged a spaceship would
look like
and uh and i think that
vss imagine is exactly what i imagined
it to be like and
i think the engineering team have just
done a magnificent job
um it's it's lighter than our first
spaceship uh vss unity
uh it's as you can see um crafted with
chrome
um so that uh on on the uh you know when
it's in space it'll
uh reflect back to earth and uh you know
kids who are watching
the spaceship uh from earth will be able
to uh
see it see the sun uh bouncing off it
um and um uh yeah it's it it's um
tremendously exciting it's been a long a
long journey to get this far
um but we've got an incredible few
months and
of milestones ahead and for people at
home thinking right now how much do i
have in the piggy bank for that 250 000
ticket price what do you get exactly
what is the experience
well first of all i think in in the
years to come uh the price will come
down i mean in the short term it'll go
up into you know what whilst people
you know who can afford it can help us
fund uh what's
you know what's not in an expensive
operation but in the long term
uh the price will come down and and
hopefully a lot of people watching this
program
um you know will be able to go to space
um but
um you know but what they'll do is
they'll climb into uh most likely
uh either bss unity or bss imagine
um and they'll be uh taken up by
our mothership um up up to about 35 000
feet they'll be dropped
uh they'll um they'll file the rocket
they'll go from naught to uh three and a
half thousand miles an hour in eight
seconds
um and when they're in space um they'll
be able to unbuckle
um float around we have these massive
big windows they'll be able to look out
of and
look back at look back at this beautiful
earth um
and they will have become astronauts and
and they'll have i think the ride of a
lifetime
in in uh in the craft of you know one of
the most beautiful craft i think ever
ever
ever built i i think it's fair to say it
is a gorgeous uh spaceship uh i want to
go to
michael now uh i'm i'm interested in
having gail king become an astronaut one
day
uh so my question to you the date for
people going up in this uh spacecraft
has been pushed ahead to
early 2022 it's been a long process as
richard pointed out how confident are
you
in 2022 as being the actual uh go
date for people launching
so we've got four flights that we've
announced uh we are planning to get back
to space
uh in new mexico in may and following
that flight
uh we have two fully crewed flights the
first of those will be just internal
mission specialist
and the one following will actually have
richard joining us
and it's really to kind of showcase
what's the private astronaut experience
going to be and uh we think
who better than richard to demonstrate
that i will have another flight with
italian air force that will showcase the
scientific uh research capabilities
and then as you said when we get into 22
we expect to open up
for all the private astronauts to go but
following the flight we do with richard
this summer
we plan to open up sales again and uh
looking forward for people
it's exciting able to sign up and come
to space with us michael what i'm really
asking is how long do i have to convince
gayle king
to spring for a ticket and become a
private astronaut you have a question
about flight that you want i do actually
because
listen richard i i think i agree with
tony i think the spaceship is very cool
tony and michael i like
richard when you said it's a ride of a
lifetime but i am curious about the
price you said it's going to go down and
be more affordable what's your
definition of affordable
i'm curious what is do you have a number
on that yet
well um
richard our plan is to is to build
um a number of spaceships and so we
could maybe get up sort of four or five
hundred flights a year
and and then we will try to get it down
to a price where
um as many people as possible are able
to go up but
i think i won't forecast um exactly how
low we'll be able to get it otherwise
nobody will buy the price and
buy the tickets today the higher cost
michael as you know jeff bezos is
watching or
does he have something to worry about
well you know i think it's really
important that the idea of going to
space starts to get normalized
because it's not something people are
used to doing and we're excited for
a lot of people to go into space and
make that something that everybody sees
is
something that they're aspiring to i
think we're going to have a really
unique
focus on owning our part of space and
that will be
really on the people themselves and
their ability to look back to the planet
so uh
we're excited for the blue origin folks
but we're very confident that what we're
going to have is really unique
all right cool we are very excited for
you light the fires and kick the tires
so richard branson
and michael cole glazer we appreciate
you being on